this is Cora the season premiere of
season 4 after all these years which god
it's been so long since we've seen a
core episode isn't it I mean God it's
felt like I've been waiting weeks Oh
weeks you weeks which I mean it is one
advantage to Nickelodeon not giving a
flying crap yes know whatever it ya know
whatever get it out of the way we're
punchball know it is interesting cuz
like I assumed we would need a year I
mean it's like they must have done these
back-to-back uh yeah some fan was asking
what do they just not give a shit about
this show why they releasing it over a
I'm like no of course that but at least
it worked in our favor
ya know which is but it's interesting
because this episode starts years later
like three years later uh which I highly
applaud I think that's a great idea
uh and we allow characters to grow up
and be a little different special II for
it being the last season and we have
years later things are almost under
control a little too bit under control
we have this uh well know things aren't
under control at all you've got one side
of the earth Kingdom bringing unity
while george w king george w bush is
about to get crap I don't know if I'm
talking about the control that is being
done you know leaving the Nazis yeah I
love it we got Nazis now exit yeah so we
pretty much have um I just call her cell
because I forget a real name uh what is
it again the the characters made that is
kuvira kokuboro yeah yeah
Rizzo kuvira come spell with you but my
avatar name logic it should be
pronounced Luke so I please make no
sense I pondered L because L de Williams
uh voice is her uh I think it's kuvira
yeah it's pretty much going through and
trying to bring balance to a pretty
destroyed you know a couple again not
just the earth Kingdom but I mean like
there's you know people separate and
choosing sides and she's bringing order
and she's bringing food and protection
but it's very clearly her order and one
order one rule and I gotta say is
Princess Zelda is pretty badass
ah it's it's and you will get to that in
a second so uh you have that you have
the air nomads you got the kids growing
up and they're trying to protect the
place you have formerly yeah
one guy come on Society which we're
already placing bets then the the bandit
was working for Princess Zelda yeah that
is our thoughts kookaburra we're just
gonna call it princess oh yeah I mean I
just I it's too hard for me remember
your names
fillie mousekewitz oh that would be an
interesting twist
her name is mousekewitz fillie
mousekewitz uh so and uh yeah and big
thing we not until the very end have we
seen Korra who is apparently doing UF's
you of you you ec earthbending
championship I guess I'm also badass in
its own way even though she sucks yeah
and get her ass handed to her not
claiming she's the avatar just walks
away and that's pretty much where it
ends uh I will say this it's a great
sign that you really figured out how to
start off your series when it just
literally ended on that one note I was
like yeah whatever happened today the
avatar bride anyway and she's like I
wouldn't know and boom end credits I'm
like son of a bitch shit like oh man I'm
just gonna say Oh out hooked I fucking
love this episode I love the setup
I love the the dread that's being built
and it's just all these pieces what we
wanted all along sequences actual
consequence and and it's very it's very
political uh which I think would be kind
of boring but again even with the what
started off political like it just ended
sloppily but the whole aman thing was a
political move yeah I mean what like
yeah how do I say they were more like
communist though yeah but you know what
I mean it was more like you know things
are good they're starting to get out of
hand now it's like shit is really
the fan a lot of things are you know
really thrown out of line and stuff and
how do we get this balance back and this
general Zelda is pretty much doing it
but how well is she doing and how much
controls in general you see Disney the
promotion come from princess to general
if she's an open up kuvira princess
generally says everything now that then
Queen General General Queen I think
that's where they're going with this but
but that's what to fear but but I I like
it because you know she's trying to have
this guy owns this town this earth
Kingdom town uh handover a leadership
pretty much to her and her protection
everything and he can retain his
position just under her supervision yeah
so it's this thing where it's like on
the one hand it's like you can see this
going bad it seems like it's already
going bad and people are splitting and
stuff at the same time what I like about
it is that a she is getting food and
protection to these people but at what
cost uh and see you in dire times I
think they're doing very good at showing
in dire times you do need sort of these
tough dire choices turn how far do you
go when people turn the leaders and not
always leaders that are best for a
country in times of crisis yeah I'm
laughing at that cuz I was like when she
was feeding the people and you know you
sit there versus well she's feeling like
she's doing right and all I could think
of was like you know interwar Germany
the fixer oh yeah trains run on time
it's all good yeah yeah with the flip
soldiers come out covered in metal
they're the face list I know you -
really well what could go wrong here
yeah um but but you still get it it's
like because they gave you a reason why
you would turn to these people yeah and
which is how all thuggish organisations
the really I don't want to say good ones
but the ones that least know what
they're doing how to actually bring
people in that's what they do they
provide basic services they provide this
and that so that then when they want to
take over the world or be total raging
douchebags everybody that's labeled as
the other you're already like well I
guess they fed me I can go along with
this but I'll make a little bit you know
I don't want say an argument for general
Zelda but it's more than fucking Nazi no
no no no no so it's I know
I want to say that I as of now just this
first episode of her character if I had
to guess I always say it's not as much
like she wants to roll just so she can
have power at least she doesn't think it
is I think she thinks that the world is
I mean even with those people that tried
to stop the train she thinks to herself
these people don't know how to protect
themselves I need to protect them from
themselves they're just gonna run
themselves into the ground I'm gonna
keep order I'm gonna keep balance but
too much is gonna be sacrificed I think
she actually notice what you kept doing
there I'm I know no exactly no that is
the problem but I'm saying that's not
just I want power I think it is much
more I want balance and I'm the only one
who can always come from a place of I'm
above the rest of you correct
join me and I will help you pe ins out
but at the same time we see she's good
at what she does so much order so I
really like that and I learned sentiment
in a good fascist type of organization
does you know you get the services out
there get your name up there branded
well and then next thing you know it's
like oh well now everybody trusts us we
can do what we want yeah um and I I love
how they kept Corrin till the end I mean
you don't see it's rebuild up and a
great reveal I turn to you like I think
when she was signing uh when the
governor was signing over the kingdom um
I turned to it I was like you know what
I really liked about this episode you
were like well what's up assume and I'm
like well yeah goes that saying that you
know whatever really like you're like
what and I'm like there's something key
here you were just like we haven't seen
Korra at all I'm like yeah I really like
that you don't see core until the last
like 10 seconds of it I think perfect I
think it's great cos mal are you setting
up a lot and you're setting up what can
go wrong under the guise of what's going
right but yeah you're pretty much
keeping your main character out of the
first episode years later and you have
no idea where she is and you find that
she lied about where she was for months
and she's actually you know getting her
ass kicked at whatever you easy and yeah
it's a great reveal it's great build up
and it's just you you I've seen let's
there you go you AFC um if I had one
criticism and it really is my only
criticism I think this episode is great
uh that new
earth king it's like okay yeah he's
supposed to be a like way supposed to be
a douche manusia noise yeah he's really
annoying you think they're drawing him
YW because the way they did his face I
mean they're obviously making him an
idiot so the way they did his face
though he's got kind of the big ears and
the sort of bushy eyebrows I like I kept
getting this vibe off of him like is
this a big poof I don't know if I think
yes I see just a coincidence you know W
is a very specific that whole
administrative very specific kind of
incompetent and I wasn't quite getting
it here you know and that's not like
your fight kid aspect to this guy though
that I don't know I reminded me of I
couldn't grab what uh you know what kind
of idiot they were going for you just
seem like a pampered idiot and that's it
I think they just want somebody who's so
incompetent that it's just gonna make it
an easy choice between when obviously
general Zelda has princess Hitler and
you know the incompetent George W Bush
tide so when because the two are
obviously gonna go head to head if he's
being coordinated and she's taking over
the earth Kingdom yeah so and I like
that it's it's almost like like a civil
war like the Russian Civil War where
everybody's now picking sides because
you have Bolin with kuvira and you've
got a mock oh now body guarding the
earth King to be and then you've got
other split ups elsewhere it's just I
don't know where Asami's falling into
this well and what I like that was cool
by the way she's kind of aged ya know
I'm not like hotter my gosh no I like
everyone's age everyone's changed a
little bit a lot of them are doing
long-distance relationships now cuz
they're trying to bring the world back
together uh they even address the
spirits thing with a republic city and I
like how they go back and they're like
all thanks for Korra den she could do
great of course like they you completely
forget that they hated her yeah but you
works a lot of times presidents you hate
sad presents later it's is like oh my
god he was so great ya know it yeah I
really like a political aspect of this
what you're right the first one did have
a lot of political leaning but this one
it's like again you sort of feel like
man this is this is really tough to kind
of say we're in the believers I think
you can't know where it's going well
yeah you couldn't
but here's the thing that the first
season being the first season you had to
just start off from a blank slate oh
sure yeah no no this one they have all
the advantage of the stuff that came
before and they'd be like okay well the
earth Kingdom fell we had all the cool
stuff that happened in season three
like really season three was a good
chunk of the set up here was season two
doing some of the work well and it is in
again because I was always saying like I
want three to kind of be bigger uh this
is kind of what I was hoping it would
build up to I fail but this is it though
like ya know I'm down right I'm totally
fine with it
uh and I think it's better they sort
come like I said the third season sir
comes from a place of just again as I
said before just some assholes you know
uh where now it's like we're in this big
political choose aside who you gonna be
with who's the real leader who's running
things we sense you know it does yeah I
was thinking because we were talking
about it in the last season he was like
well it's just a bunch of assholes but
I'm like how many of history's greatest
disasters were started by just some
assholes well now shoots an Archduke we
get World War one that spawns World War
two bunch of guys get on some airplanes
and 9/11 and now we've got like two wars
our country's involved in in all of this
chaos and a few people can really do a
lot of damage and that seems to be Diggs
actly what happened no so so it was a
good um it was a good setup and it seems
like this season they're really gonna
lean towards the consequences of those
couple of assholes so I really like that
because like I said I really didn't know
it sees a thing I like season three a
lot but I'm like where I hope this is
going somewhere good and it looks like
it really is now uh yeah I just feel
that dread and I feel that uneasiness
could you do sort of say well if I was
in that situation like what what would I
do what what direction would I take well
I actually get bullet like when Bolin
was handing the food over to somebody
feeding them and then um what's her face
is just like looking at him just like
yes or turning away it's yeah and I
might get I was like if I were Bolin I'd
be like I'm helping people what's your
problem but you know you get her side
yeah
so it very identifiable and I think that
is sort of strangely enough the key to
good I don't want to say political drama
because I don't want to say this is a
record as a political drought that is
kind of Turing into that is that you
understand both sides whichever one do
you agree with you get sort of where
each one is coming and this feels like
the writer creators finally had the time
to flush something out like that's been
the problem on like I I'm saying now
even more I've seen this episode I love
Season one I actually really enjoyed
season one season one's completely
pointless nothing to do with any of the
rest of this not a single damn thing
I've seen so many explanations trying to
well but he gave them the spiritual
ability to get that I might know season
two completely retcon then started over
it's like hey Nickelodeon just said give
us three seasons from the very start
we're now gonna dick you around just
give us three seasons whatever you want
to do how much better do you think this
would have actually been like as a
consistent store I can't see these
people saying we'll give you three
season then they turn out anything good
I mean I know right if his face taught
us anything right
oh but like it seems like they got so
under the gun of well we've only got one
season we'll have that one wrap-up with
a happy ending because we don't know if
we're gonna get any more than the last
like an O we're gonna give you three
since after all it's like well shit well
now we just like blew half iwata gotta
make it bigger we need more characters
and stuff and second season like her
already into this point where she's
advanced but now we're starting over so
we have to redo it again and what and
it's very I need with the timing it's
very clear season three and Fort Worth
done back to back and with more of a
concept of where they were going with
yeah so that's why I think like it
thanks a lot Nick this is well but we do
get these two seasons
oh we do and these two seasons as are
quite fast and season two had moments
that were really strong I uh I've
insisted you I already had a lot of very
strong yeah and I've always loved the
mythos at the end going into the
backstory of their world like fleshing
out that mythology so that's something
that season two gave us and you can
never take away despite the fact in the
end
is in the middle I like retarted strong
and ended strong I'll argue season two
head even more than it because I do love
the twins I love the way it started I
love the way it ended I mean that
there's a strong you know a big finish
to that season I agree and just a good
thing to kind of disconnected from three
and four so far like now I'm looking
back and it's more connected than one is
well that is the other thing too is that
like they did address the spirit thing
and yeah me just my bitching and stuff
it's like I'd like to see more spirits
and stuff but they only said no they at
least addressed it that there are
they're giving along and you sort of see
how to get along - it's a little kind of
early then retrospect I'm actually
starting to side with you on that cuz
I'm like I feel like we've gone through
a whole season three and out of the
beginning of season four it's like and
now they're magically living together
and I'm like that was really the huge
basis of season two and you just sort of
kind of forgot about it and just kind of
like well okay tommy was gonna come back
in season four here but I didn't see any
hints trapped at all if anything it's
just like well they learned to deal with
it and Republic City looks like the
Mushroom Kingdom
mmm that's pretty much it it's like
Super Mario Brothers going it's like
well we adapted I guess I'm like okay
hmm
as you know all you know races and
people or whatever kept in my edges we
own together three years again if
there's anything history issued is that
the end of the world because I think
this story's way more interesting yeah
so I just would have liked them to kind
of come to a conclusion with that
somewhere and that just be like and it
was all magically off-screen in these
three years that we didn't show you oh
yeah no I mean I would like if it came
because it looks like they're just sort
of and that's done next
ah but between season three in this
opening episode like I'm hoping this
continues cuz I think they found my
groove again I'm really all the kicking
around they find yeah I don't know I
feel like this great it sounds weird but
it's like there's this turning in my
stomach of what's gonna happen but I me
them a good way kind of like watching
Game of Thrones know what's gonna happen
it's like I know that I don't like it's
on my plate I got that board of our
English middle part Empire Strikes Back
feel of like bad shits going down you're
just a nervous relic hair yeah of
something we
really big and really important yeah and
I really like that I think for a final
season that's such a good way to set up
everything and I'm really excited well
it was a tense first episode it was even
the music couple times can like yeah
like kind of making you uneasy and
everything's sort of unpleasant and
there's big question marks everywhere
but it's not just you point and say bad
guy here's why just take over world yet
like I said I think you really can she
is most likely gonna be the villain and
you can Greg it's pretty clear yeah but
I mean it's I like that you can watch
and you can say I see I see her mindset
about why she thinks this can work it's
not just I'm gonna release evil you know
cuz I'm an evil nut you know it's that
they're you know or I'm an ant or kiss
or something it's like no there really
is an order and I can bring that order
and I will like these people just need
to see it and you know it's not gonna
worry at the same time you get it you
get why she wit is funny because I think
now we were talking about this last
season because we didn't know where this
season was gonna go yet but now I think
we've got all the four major kind of
political groups you've got we start off
with communist everything must be equal
then we started off with the religious
nut bags mmm and then we had the
anarchist and now we've got fascists
yeah like we've done all the big isms no
way which is kind of cool actually yeah
but but this one like I say I can't I I
think it may be more for adults I don't
know me not for kids but I think uh we
can relate to it more because I mean we
have seen I mean growing up we have seen
places I've gone to rubble and try to
bring it back you know other countries
and even sometimes here and sometimes
I'm time to be caused then yeah I mean
but but through the actual attempt of
trying to bring it back and try and
rebuild it and giving control to people
that we trust
sometimes we trust them too much or
sometimes they ask too much and it's but
it's a tough line to draw it actually is
sometimes you know very tricky to go
where and when
sometimes these people are gonna say
he's just there calling the shots and
you have no choice so it's I'm really
intrigued by and I was really good yeah
I as much as I like season three I
camera the last time I was like what
really excited for the next one this was
like I'm really excited really hyped to
see where this is going even breaking
out all of the villains in season three
of their various prisons which was
really badass I still think this episode
blows everything season three yeah hi
everyone
I am totally wrapped up yeah I I can't
even think of it with the exception
maybe a little bit of the earth prince
or King whatever and he was in a you
know it's like that's why I'm like okay
can we fast-forward this but like I just
everything I'm just like why is gonna
happen
oh my god like I was so invested I am
just like super hype for this season as
I said that ending when it just cut to
the end credits and she's like I don't
know
I'm just like oh god damn it what is be
an hour so no but what we're very
excited so I'm down the avatar
keep it going